and if we're in a virtual reality
already why would you divert yourself
into another one that is even less real
more or less has less value yeah you
know towards our personal growth yes but
if we don't begin disarmament globally
there's no path forward to peace and
prosperity for everybody
yeah it just isn't gonna happen one twig
you've been snapped to it's harder three
it's almost impossible that's the
strength of the family yeah and that's
the strength of dropping all our borders
too
we're under the illusion that somehow we
need them to be strong to be a strong
country no actually it makes us weaker
that perception is cutting us off
dividing us up and isolating us from
each other why did I ended up saving
three people's lives in such a short
time when I was young because it usually
that doesn't happen to people right and
I thought that was really strange what's
the purpose of it until I read this
children's book that was an opportunity
that was a gift to me yeah it the thing
is it well you know my music music or
any of the form of creativity it's like
oh I did a song so now I'm done no you
said at some point you're gonna find
another song in another song right or
you're gonna paint another picture
whatever because that's how creativity
is and each song and each painting is
slightly different and it's beautiful
they're all beautiful right well yeah if
you want to be stronger smarter
healthier and happier increase your love
quotient direct to the force or the
source or whatever you want to call it
the web of light yeah no someone's
opinion may contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sathyan we
are on site in the beautiful Palm
Springs California we are now going to
be talking about our path to peace and
prosperity we have Robert Stanley
joining us on the show hi Robert hey
Alan good to see you thanks for having
me yeah super excited for you coming on
our show now it was great being on your
unique is Radio Hour very just recently
it's a great show together it was our
first time getting to chat on line like
that and you know do it on video right
it was nice but now we get in person for
our first time which is excellent it was
so cool actually getting to finally be
in our spiritual essences together in
the same physical location for those
that don't know Roberts background
Robert Stanley's editor of unica's
magazine.com author of two books on UFOs
in Washington DC and host of unica's
Radio Hour and you can find the link in
a bio below to unica's magazine.com
and also find the first episode that we
did together that link is below as well
both parts yeah Robert we had such a
wide-ranging conversation the first time
we talked which is what I love so much
covering what is the ultimate purpose of
humanity where do we even come from the
spirit meet the body for these lessons
on this planet we covered so many cool
areas of talk we didn't really get to
got into things like the love quotient
we didn't really hammer out that this
path of optimizing peace and prosperity
and how to exactly do that and I'm
excited to talk about this with you
let's start things off with you know
this is a very interesting again just
this one idea that we are now here we
there's something instead of nothing
there's life instead of nothing and when
we come here we have this consciousness
this perception system to engage with
each other and
and maximize flourishing and creative
expression and all these things you know
we have trillions of dollars of money
every single year being poured into war
and violence and there's malevolence
among us and that's kind of like this
excuse that's been being propagated like
there's an there's a nastiness in them
and so it's really important for us to
put up these walls and these these types
of things to protect ourselves how do we
transcend this monkey politics and these
monkey wars and harmonize ourselves
collectively with nature and each other
to be this pinnacle civilization that we
can be
yeah the first step is realizing that
we're all family and I know that's gonna
be hard for a lot of people that have
prejudices for generations you know as
you said that's an excuse for bad
behavior basically actually we usually
attract people to us that we that have
qualities that we dislike in ourselves
and rather than taking care of those
things we say oh they're the problem if
I just do something to them you know
punish them or kill them that I'm gonna
feel better about myself in fact it
doesn't work and as it never worked it
never will work so all of the weapons
systems that we have designed and
developed over thousands of years of
this current civilization are not making
us safer and they never will make us
safer they cannot only we can by
increasing the love ocean in our heart
and reaching out to others especially
those that we don't agree with and and
because just threatening them obviously
is going to escalate it's like pouring
gasoline on a fire it's not the path to
peace and prosperity you know peace has
to come before we can all prosper that's
that's my understanding about the
process is really pretty simple and yet
difficult okay I mean it's it's not
complicated
it's just freaking hard because we have
we including myself have all these
prejudices and just negativity that um
especially when we get together
collectively and point fingers or
weapons it escalates the negativity to a
point where ultimately everything
collapses it's it's a I told you this
was pretty amazing to me I only found it
out recently the dark side actually
serves a purpose and it's not limited to
just this world I just want to make this
really clear to everybody up front mmm
this was a huge revelation to me because
I've been trying to figure it out I've
had really really intimate experiences
with what I would consider evil yes okay
so who's to blame well apparently it was
inherently designed it's a program
designed into creation as we understand
it that is like a circuit breaker when
there's too much negativity the circuit
breaks and the system stops it just
collapses on itself and then it'll it'll
reset and it'll kind of come back and if
it works in balance if there's enough
love or spirituality and science is in
balance then the civilization will go to
the next level you know the spirituality
and science those are just words the
things that drive that though are us are
intense you know and our intent if it's
based on fear that's where all the
weapons come from anymore ok so then
it's one of the main ways maybe to view
it is that if we from within ourselves
are cultivating fear then we cultivate
war if we from within ourselves called
cultivate love then we cultivate peace
and it can be as simple as that and then
so then it's like and then it kind maybe
gets a little bit more nuanced where it
it's like okay well
we have we have something that's cooking
up with it within us from these
different pockets of being raised in
different cultures around the world with
different amounts of socioeconomic
status different like privileges
accesses the basic needs were
indoctrinated into different religions
these types of things and then in some
ways like love becomes obfuscated and we
have to like pierce the veil that is the
matrix that were put into to realize
that it is all love yeah and so we then
we then it's it's an educate it seems
like it's an education problem with all
children that are being born into the
world plus existing adults plus the
matrix itself has an issue with the
illusion of separation and the illusion
of of propagation of fear and weapons
and types of faith in these types of
things which is like it's obfuscated
that that all-encompassing unbounded
love you know you said a key word there
was cultivate and if you think of this
as a garden and that we are seeds our
souls are like seeds of light in this
garden here you could say that the
negativity the fear is like weeds and it
chokes out what we can consider
bountiful or good herbs and plants that
are life-giving right so our sustaining
and so how do you tend the garden you
select those that you consider to be
what I just said and you eradicate
you've got to pull out the weeds
occasionally you have to you have to
tend the garden although I think it goes
it goes awry again I think that's
built-in inherent I only now understand
the importance of that we have to
participate it's participatory ok we
can't just sit there go okay you know
give me abundance give me peace no you
we have to work on it every day we
literally have to pull weeds of
negativity out of our hearts every day
because like in a garden you there are
weeds seeds from the weeds that are
constantly falling into the soil from
wherever you know wind Animatrix and
they're looking for fertile soil too and
if you don't do something - the thing is
most people I believe most people in
this planet feel like oh we've got it
we've got a you know murder all the
murderers you know we'll wait a second
that's not the path to peace it starts
in beside each and every one of us and
then it becomes a collective as we start
to congregate and cooperate and
collaborate you know come in a
compassionate way it's something
realistic okay not not not religious
because to me religion has been
weaponized I think or politicized at the
very least the Ovid oftentimes it goes
hand in hand with with martial actions
or reactions but again it this is
completely up to us this isn't up to a
government or a religion that's kind of
one bringing them into it because we are
of religion we are government
okay well every time we participate
we're endorsing it and giving it life
and extending it into the future so and
you know a lot of people I've talked to
on my show when I asked about spiritual
matters that I get people saying well I
used to be I was raised a Catholic I
used to go search but I'm not doing that
anymore I said what you're still a
spiritual person aren't you yeah well
then if you know that if you feel that
essence of your soul what are you doing
with that because just being passive is
it's not really solving the problem
because the problem is not just mine or
yours it's everybody we're all in this
together yeah yeah that we're not all
vibing on a divine wavelength that it's
a miracle that we're all here that
that evil serves a purpose of creating
all these obfuscation zhh to make it
hard for us to actually realize how to
work together and so actually it ensures
it ensures that we work hard to get it
in a peaceful loving manner because if
we don't the system collapsed every time
you look in history but you said a
circuit breaker yeah yeah 90 and my
understanding is that's universal and it
makes sense because if one planet just
one planet were to develop into like a
Star Trek or Star Wars kind of scenario
and it was to spread across all the
creation eventually exponentially it
would start to infect all of creation so
this was brilliant honestly so evil is
the circuit breaker it's it's like a
Fermi filter as well these these filters
of either asteroid collisions or nuclear
wars or diseases or pandemics or rapid
wealth inequality or any types of
civilizational collapses endeavors into
godlike powers without moral spiritual
ethical evolution and then these are
like circuit breakers to make it so that
these Fermi filters so that the like you
said if a civilization gets into these
later stages of evolution they can go
and like spread themselves like a virus
to science its scientific development
without spiritual balance yeah that's
the way it's been presented to me in a
children's book yeah
allegedly a children's book about you
know a friendly extraterrestrial giving
children leave ice because they're in
the future saying let me show you what a
civilized world really looks like yeah
because you don't live on a soup pot
it's a girl and that I know is shocking
to a lot of us and we so called Western
civilization we think that we are
civilized well yeah maybe compared to
somebody that lives in the jungle with
sticks and stones but in the bigger
scheme of things we are not we are not
despite whatever technology we have that
is not a metric
of one's level of civilization or
civility I should say right it's really
a lot simpler than that
it's not about technology it's about
your love quotient that we were talking
about before and how so how do you
measure that though yeah how do you
measure will be key to big judge them by
their deeds not their words because in
certain ones of us that are so called
pathological yeah they're very skilled
at lying because they're predators they
are embodying the dark side so they bail
it based so they would see somebody like
you and I as weak because they think
that if they trick us you know they can
take advantage of this because we are
supposedly defenseless because we want
peace right and prosperity for everybody
and basically all they want is something
for themselves again those people
present an obstacle but it can be easily
overcome without punishing them because
ultimately and this was the other thing
that I learned recently we punish
ourselves I know that for a fact
and
one of the hardest things to do is
forgive yourself it doesn't mean excuse
your behavior I'm talking about truly
forgiving yourself because you screwed
up and everybody does by the way okay
but if you cannot forgive yourself
you'll never be able to forgive anybody
else you'll never be able to move
forward emotionally and like you say
cultivate cultivate this heart space so
that so that the love energy has a place
to resonate I'm sorry I'm touching this
I prize excuse me there's something I
could [ __ ] these people hear this thump
yeah sorry anyway it's a it's really not
that complicated it's just hard it
really is I actually had a panic attack
years ago here in Palm Springs because I
was flashing back on things that
happened to me when I was a child as my
parents and it was it was really
traumatic I mean you know I don't think
anybody has a so-called perfect
childhood and the difference is do I see
myself as a victim or a survivor and if
I was a victim that is a that's a
dissonant position to take that's that's
basically like I give up I'm helpless
and helpless and somebody else I'm
advocating it's ability in all of this
whereas as a victim is actually
empowered to to heal themselves and
others that they can relate to through
their pain and the healing because once
you allow yourself to say I survived
this I am stronger for this I have
healed this wound and a big part of it
actually the key element the reason I
bring it up is because I decided I would
forgive myself for her and then I would
give my parents yeah for because you
know they're not perfect and I know they
were doing the best they could but it
was bad it was really bad they fought a
lot and it frightens kids you know to
see that their whole support system is
just like Talega
and like emotional earthquake yes and
and you know who you're gonna turn to as
a kid you don't have a lot of options
because they're your support system and
they're just constantly fighting and
you're like well yeah it's it's so on
some level people shut down I did on
some level emotionally I shut down but
after I got married and I had a kid we
came out here we were vacationing it was
like oh wait a minute mother and dad and
the little boy all over again in organs
and that stuff that I was suppressing
you know trying to like forget it just
came popping back up and I was like I
just felt like I was having a heart
attack but that's how panic attacks are
I wasn't gonna die but I realized that I
wasn't really living either
I I wasn't living my life and I mean in
this regard I wasn't emotionally
available 100% for my wife and my son
and that is that is cruel um especially
since you were just talking about your
need as a child yeah yeah why would I
pass that on correct yeah you want to
stop the trauma right yeah it's a little
bit like the vampire City you know it
doesn't always have to be sexual with
trauma abuse comes in many different
forms and it is what you call a
contagious because it is because we're
emotional beings it's past past
wonderful you know it's so anyway I'm
just saying from experience that was a
turning point I probably would need to
be sitting here talking to you about
these matters if I hadn't come to that
key awareness yes the other thing that
happened
it was about it was pouring rain here
which is kind of a weird thing and there
was rainbows everywhere but at the same
time I think it was Phuket it was
Thailand they had a huge earthquake and
a tidal wave and it killed a bunch of
people and I'm like watching this on the
news it was Christmas time here and
there's all these people getting killed
by a tidal wave and that brought up all
kinds of memories when I was a kid
growing up in Malibu on the beach I used
to have dreams about terrible nightmares
about people getting killed by a tidal
wave you know so it was it was
triggering something like an emotional
tidal wave in me at that moment and it
was so weird because the juxtaposition
of hey I've got a beautiful wife a
beautiful son look at all these rainbows
and yet like I'm I'm having this like
like knockout drag-out fight with this
like inner demons they call them that's
typically wouldn't we call them now and
the pills won't help let me tell you
that sorry
nope all the talk therapy in the world
because the therapist can't actually do
the work for you yet right and a lot of
them a lot of those people are damaged
themselves yeh and that's why they go
into that field and I'm glad that they
do but I try I went down that path and
ultimately it didn't help it didn't help
me at all I found out I told him telling
you that was the only way that for me
anyway to heal myself since yourself
work and and ultimately be available to
be a dad to be a husband stop the
transgenerational try and actually be a
son to my parents you know because I was
kind of ideal as I was carrying a grudge
yeah and that's just a wall man that's
just a [ __ ] emotional wall yeah yeah
you know you're making really clear that
love and the path to peace and
prosperity starts within from examples
like what you just listed there so we
all have some sort of a trauma or some
sort of an ancestral trauma or some sort
of a of a birthplace
shoo around the time that we were young
throughout our first couple months or
years of life where something had built
up and that it's up to us to treat it
like a challenge that we want to
overcome on the other side of this the
trauma is the treasure is those yeah our
biggest levels up in life are right
there right in front of us and so we
gotta if we remember that and we do that
then we become more loving towards our
ancestors our parents our kids etc the
people around us in our communities then
the love spreads it butterfly max like
that yeah and so then that's how we get
to that peace and prosperity through our
own self work so that's kind of like one
of the most if not the most important
pillars well yeah start without the work
yeah hardcore self work right because if
you feel yourself then you're in a
position to help others heal themselves
as opposed to because you can't impose
that on anybody all right because you
know they're gonna resist if a person's
not like seriously you you know it's
it's so intimately personal those
emotions are all about you and for
somebody else to come in and that's why
I say the therapists are really very
limited what they can do let's let's
revisit also what you said it about the
garden as well this is a really good
analogy that I think would be useful to
unpack further let's see how we can play
tennis on it so so the let's let's see
so the seed is the child that's born
into the world and they come with this
you know this unique DNA that gets to be
expressed their creative fruits get to
be brought into the world but they need
the root system in place of love
compassion the water food a shelter etc
and so what we see is that like this
these seeds are in the garden and so
it's both within our only seed as our
seat flourishes we have to do that self
work which is kind of like identifying
the weeds plucking them out and it's
also watering our own roots with like
exercise sleep yeah meditation right
yeah and then that's what waters and
also surrounding ourselves with people
that are smarter than us and like and
and creating more value than we capture
and spending some time in nature is
really just I know a lot of us right now
are so caught up in digital you know
reality or simulation I mean we talk is
this a digital simulation it doesn't
matter it's it's a virtual reality okay
and we have a role to play here but I
think we're being completely distracted
by digital technology right now what
we're preventing ourselves to do it's a
challenge it's just it's just another
obstacle I'm not saying it's evil it's
just it's it's taking us away from it's
disconnecting us from the the purpose
our purpose you know in a lot of ways I
see people are just so caught up in it
and it's it isn't real and if we're in a
virtual reality already why would you
divert yourself into another one that is
even less real one less has less value
yeah you know towards our personal
growth yes now that's it that's a cool
way to put it that since we're already
immersed as a character in this game
that we need to be focusing on our
levelling up and when we go to these
devices that mostly
distract us away from that leveling up
process it's actually less meaningful
all that type of stuff
since I play tennis a lot if if I'm
playing tennis and there's a little
break time like we're somebody setting
up for where their server or whatever we
have like kind of going on here we're
not hitting the ball yeah I'll look over
to the other court yeah and see what's
going on because tennis players don't
like that we kind of want to watch and
see you know if somebody's playing well
you're like oh well you see monkey do
well kind of like that I mean it's it's
there's an interest level there totally
and it's very distracting to when you're
on the court and somebody else is
playing and they're like getting into it
and you're you're just looking over
there but you cannot tell you it takes
you away from being in the moment it's a
matter of fact one of the things I think
there's a book called the Zen of tennis
or the Dao of ten essentially the DAO of
tennis it says that the less you think
the better you play yeah the same thing
with when I freestyle with hip-hop music
or when you do an interview it's the
same thing as an airlock you know or as
the person that's being interviewed yeah
just flow flow instead of well because
they analyze because think less feel
more it allows you to add reconnect with
the moment yeah because if I'm thinking
about if I'm thinking about a hundred
things before the ball you discussed
yeah yeah that means I am not open to
the moment I am like I'm a caught in a
virtual moment in my mind instead of
just being in that flow at that at the
real moment you know connecting with
that ball is all I should be thinking
about so there's little tricks for this
in tennis anyway it's just just looking
at the ball or listening so one of the
hardest things to do is actually listen
to the ball being hit and then come
whizzing over and then bouncing you
whatever the technique is that allows
you to stay focused
there that's what you should use yes
okay and that's why again I feel really
bad about digital technology it started
with with radio was fine originally but
when TV came along and they started
flashing all these lights at a certain
rate and and in training our
thought process it totally ripped us out
of reality took us into yeah the subset
yes yes and yet the the immersive
experiences that are distractive and
consumptive and that are hijacking our
dopaminergic reward system versus ones
that enable us to hold these techniques
of focus towards our ultimate North Star
endeavors and I love this analogy of the
garden and I'm sure we'll end up
revisiting it but I just I just really
like this one the garden so it's like
cultivating our own self self work our
own self love bringing up our love
quotient butterflying how that affect
out and then seeing more peace and
prosperity that sense and then on a I
just like a global level of monkey
politics in war and in it's just is the
way that the disarmament happens is
through the self work and self love and
then spreading that with the butterfly
effect is that how we do the disarmament
overtime well guess what if nobody
bought the arms wouldn't matter how many
they make no does these guys need to
make a profit right but if they make all
the armament and nobody uses it they're
out of business the idea is that if I if
we all agreed to not use it and then one
person does use it right that's kind of
like this well if that purpose there's
always gonna be here's the other thing
to people that don't have access to
weapons will find a an ingenious way to
act out their negativity like we see
with these people driving trucks on to
church you know pedestrian pathways so
so it isn't just about disarmament
although that's is a huge issue because
it's gotten so far out of hand that if
we don't begin disarmament globally
there's no path forward to peace and
prosperity for everybody
yeah it just isn't going to happen and
another
the big one is just that it's it's not
just like 800 billion dollars in the
United States but it's like trillions of
dollars globally and it's become an
industrial complex and it now has what
is called an embedded growth obligation
and so there's a person there's a
perpetual state of status quote that it
has now and - and - the basically every
child that's born into the world now is
born into the ideology of their the
world war one world war two cold war
just they're still ongoing wars around
going around the plate of refugee camps
around the planet drones that are
constantly monitoring inner contests of
ballistic missiles fighter jets like
we're just born into that paradigm right
and so to get out of that rut is is we
it's like a whole ethos change
civilizational ethos change that process
of self love just updating the code away
from war and towards peace but
simultaneously recognizing that not
everyone around the planet is just going
to become self loving overnight what is
that and so because of that then there's
like we all do our best to level up our
love while simultaneously staying
slightly vigilant - just in case some
people are not yes you can defend
yourself but here's one thing I read
last night that I thought was really
profound I had I never heard this before
it was Gary Zhukov was writing in his
one of his books because he was a green
beret now if you know that about Gary
she's a fantastic teacher but when I
read that I really started to understand
him a little better and he said he was
reciting a particular time in Gandhi's
life when he went up into the on
Mountain tribe I think he was in
Afghanistan
and and these were very warlike you know
they say series people you don't want to
mess with them right because they're
they all have weapons and they they'll
shoot you right and he says I have no
fear yeah I have no fear and he went to
speak to one of their their their you
know councils and he's and and he he
told them he says you only need that if
you have fear you only need weapons if
you have fear great interesting and and
ultimately the weapons cannot dissipate
the fear only love can do this and when
he explained this you know however he
explained this to the tribal leaders the
tallest burly is most well you know the
alpha male yeah he put is he put his
rifle down in front of Gandhi said okay
yeah I understand I will follow you I'm
I'm willing to follow you yeah you know
you're a little guy he did you say you
have no Sierra yeah and you're going to
teach me to have no fear without my
weapon yeah I want you to show me this
and he became he became a faithful
companion for the rest of Gandhi's life
he followed this man because he believed
that that was an something that he'd
never even considered before okay
because it's like a yeah yeah during
that rut that indoctrinated process yeah
but again it's just a fear I like that
fear leads to weapons and love leads to
peace yeah interesting yeah yeah and you
can't see the thing about it is you
cannot enforce peace on others you yeah
you know you can help ask people
questions which then lead them to
process of self-reflection when he needs
them to peace which leads us which leads
them to love which leads us to peace
right but is it yes the thing is that is
helping it they're so focused on the
fear unless you show them the other way
they're going to discontinue down that
what the door has to be made available
and that's what a question can do yeah
questions can show people there's an
alternative door for constantly walking
to the fear door the question
illuminates the the love door and then
they see okay well there's a love door
didn't even know that that exists now I
can try and see what it's like and feel
it maybe walk through it occasionally
yeah that leads to peace look I know
that there's a lot of people in the in
the military and other armed you know
people like first responders police
officers they they love their families
but there's still this wall up about us
and them and the truth of the matter is
that most people don't have weapons on
this planet I I never saw that in Hong
Kong and yet people still found ways on
each other like they're doing now but
generally speaking the the military
population of this planet is very small
in the United States it's only about one
percent believe it or not yeah if you
include all the veterans that are you
know and then it would be around three
percent sure but it's a really small
we're talking a very small number and I
know they seem monolithic and and like
intractable and so as far as their their
position like you know hey we're here to
protect you you don't you don't tell me
to drop our weapons because then we're
all going to be vulnerable yeah you
don't want that yeah so yeah showing its
chilling me the other way is no actually
as long as you keep quoting the weapons
and pointing them at other people within
our global family yeah we're all at risk
the beautiful world that are all our
hearts know is possible and yet it's not
the flick of a light switch which is
what makes it complicated yeah it we we
have the evil in place purposely and
then that it can't just be a flight
switch over to complete peace and
prosperity that then that makes this
process more difficult but it's still
the up leveling and consciousness around
the planet towards love and peace is
exactly what eventually leads us to that
prosperity
yeah yeah so so it has to be done
through like a grassroot style of
sincere soft work and development and
yeah I have I wanna I want to also make
sure we get to resetting the global
financial system in general yeah because
I think it's become more and more clear
through conversations we've had on the
show and more and more people talking
about it and highlighting this but like
fractional reserve banking was actually
not what was first intended when we
developed a money developed a money for
exchanging things of value for each
other and now it's turned into a Ponzi
scheme and we are literally just blinded
to what's happening behind the curtain
this big curtain of the financial system
and we're completely over it and more
and more people are waking up and saying
that I like decentralization I like the
distributed ledger technology I like
cryptocurrencies I like not having a
centralized control system over a
currency that's completely [ __ ]
manipulated and so what would it look
like to make the transition in this
reset and how would that empower us yeah
that's a good question I'm obviously not
an economist but I'm I've yet to meet
one that actually seems to know much
about the economy
whenever I listen to those people
there's only one that I actually and
she's not an economist it's Katherine
Austin Fitz is the only person that ever
makes any sense talking about how
corrupt the economy has become in the
United States I didn't think you could
actually get worse but it has stealing
trillions of dollars you know and using
the federal government to
so that's a top-down organized crime
problem it's and it's not just us I
think I mentioned this to you last time
we spoke but it the numbers I've seen
published are over 240 trillion dollars
worth of debt it's crazy that's more
that's more death and equity the whole
planet is bankrupt okay and I know some
people say oh this is you know the
breakaway civilization stole it so they
could leave the planet I don't care who
who did it the problem is it happened
you know how we gonna fix it I you know
I'm kind of the of the old-school belief
that it's called Jubilee I was told that
this is actually something that's been
done in the past
it's called debt forgiveness it's but
biblical terms it's called a Jubilee in
Native Americans terms it was called
potlatch and it's something that people
did routinely it was considered to be
something really high esteem for you for
a person to be able to give away their
stuff periodically you know kind of
start over yeah and and make sure that
everything is recycled and reset happily
unfortunately some people have to be
taken out of the system because even if
we did a global reset and researching
bad actors appear yeah they would come
back and do this same kind of criminal
activity yeah so we did this is again
this term Catherine Austin Fitz has been
so amazing when I listen to her talk but
she says we all have to participate
right now we act as though and we just
let other people take care of it we
don't realize that we're financing the
criminality the corruption is coming
right out of our own pockets are our
investments are going into these things
so yes they are disguised a lot of them
but it doesn't mean you can't do due
diligence especially in the digital age
everybody has access to that kind of
information especially if you sign up
for and this is not an endorse
for her okay Soleri report is fantastic
you can get it digitally and for sure
it'll come to you the printed version
sometimes it's interrupted I think
people don't want that information
coming out but if you're interested in
actually being proactive about you know
your money or your assets or whatever
you want to call it she should get some
really good outlines on how we can do
that from eight like you said grassroots
she actually says you it's county by
county that's how we have to work think
globally Apple oh it sees we act locally
you think globally and that's really
true that is absolutely correct because
when they say about corruption power
power actually power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
so the larger the institution there's
more likelihood that there's even
greater corruption going on totally
which is what systemic
now we're at the level of what the
initial founding fathers said was just
you know you have one person that is
representing maybe thirty thousand
people now it's one person in Congress
representing six hundred thousand people
and that's an absolute joke yeah we're
supposed to have a Congress that it's
like eight thousand people now so let's
let's really and what would that look
like how much whoa you know how big are
these government's supposed to be across
the world how much I bar how much of our
spiritual actualization can offset the
amount of corruption and greed and
whatnot that occurs I like the I like
the reset in terms of taking it from a
really grass roots county by county
level I like that I'm just this really
like what what what would what is it
that like you know cryptocurrency and
decentralization technologies are
fascinating because they kind of they
kind of go like this they kind of flip
the system on its head which is
fantastic but then this whole idea of
like county by county is like okay well
you can't get
you can get like millions of our
billions of people to sign up for
digital currencies pretty quickly but
it's much more difficult to try and get
I think from a single County oh it takes
longer at least to get it from a single
County to have all of the people in that
County have some sort of a new system of
money / trade such barter etc and then
have that slowly scale out as a system
of Finance yeah I haven't studied your
model closely enough but if I understand
it correctly or at all is that counties
invest okay it's like pension plans for
I think I have a better way to put this
okay okay I think the better way to put
this would be when we when we do a
complete reset and redesign of the way
that we exchange things of value across
our planet what would you want that to
look like well it certainly wouldn't be
based on fiat currency it may be digital
but again there has to be some sort of
mechanism where people can be
accountable because right now there is
no accountability I told you one of the
things that she brings up it's it's
called FAS B 56 and that is a new system
that they've put on into into practice
even though it's illegal but because
it's coming from the federal government
they say we we're not going to show you
our books because to the General
Accounting Office we can't show you but
our books because it's a matter of
national security
really okay so you can basically do
steal however much money you want and
never be held accountable yeah I mean
wrong so yeah because it's now tens of
trillions of dollars that she knows of
she's been able to over a period of
years and did ham
for it and any all her colleagues you
know everybody that that started to peek
behind the curtain that's kind of
corruption they're like me so we're
talking serious criminals here now what
would it look like I we've already been
down this road I mean clearly before
money people bartered services and goods
and you know if the economy yeah yeah
there's it's not buy diffic just
literally love the divinity in you and i
would be like hey wanna I have some
Apple like you wanna be an Apple
together yeah it wouldn't be like you
must pay me for this happen you know
well that's those are testing shadows
it's not real it's none of that
money is real like time this is not real
just an illusion it's a yeah it's
relative it's it's an agreed-upon you
know degree of alright so it's a subset
of the virtual reality we will keep
creating these subsets yeah like money
is another one the shared hallucination
you have money money and time and other
things it's what it does though is it
puts us in a box it's like a maze you
need a box in a box in a box and pretty
soon you're just like no I don't even
know where I am
that's it that's a great way to put it
okay the more we add shared
hallucinations which are boxes now we go
from this abundant divine spiritual
birthplace of Earth to like we're in a
10 foot by 10 foot white room in a
straitjacket and it's like yeah it's
like you must work 80 years of life to
buy your way out of this room like what
the [ __ ]
don't wear this [ __ ] yeah that's a great
way to put it the more negative shared
hallucinations the more constrictions on
our ultimate spiritual divine purpose
that are there and we don't even [ __ ]
realize like why we get hijacks also our
ability to be creative or imaginative
yeah and those two things are co-equal
unfortunately in this world we one of
the lives we've been led to believe that
is our imagination is like it's not
valuable it's not real so why give it
any validity or energy you know when in
fact imagination is is the birthplace of
all creation of all meditation yes yes
yes you know and so these these as you
call them hallucination is a sure blue
station is actually inhibit us because
like if I have if I can imagine
something beautiful and I share that
vision with you and you share with
others now pretty soon we will manifest
that yeah that that becomes reality yes
so you know dr. Martin Luther King he
had a dream he had a vision he shared it
with us and it definitely made a
difference even though he had to because
his physical life I guess you know that
was the price that had to be paid there
was a massive butterfly effect of the
great minds of that said that had were
marked martyrs for their dreams I know
he didn't want to do that yeah well
there was a lot more impact yet - ok so
but let's give that to something as
you're talking about so when we reach a
tipping point of love yes and peace on
this planet
we're going to receive a lot of help
from our extended family off this world
and not before that because not only
would it be what people could not
receive it anyway because they have so
much fear they'd be like yeah the aliens
are invading Europe but in fact they are
like I said they are extended family
they are benevolent and they do have
it's not just about technology by the
way they have some very advanced
techniques and other resources that they
would love to share with us because we
are family why wouldn't they
I'll tell you why is it because we are
so caught up in our own fears that if
and when they show up we panic and
actually it's not just we it's it's the
leadership under the current paradigm of
negativity of paranoia yeah they are
looking desperately for a way to
manufacture a threat from offworld so
that they can somehow then perpetuate
their more fear more of the fear and
their control mechanism yeah and weapons
basically yeah and they haven't been
able to figure out how to do it because
it's such a big lie yeah it's it's been
through the mother of all lies
unfortunately because it's and it's also
keeping us quantitate here that
particular that's a lie is is probably
the worst because it is it is keeping us
stuck on not only on this world but it's
preventing us from having interaction
with our family members from offworld
yeah so it's as though there's a there's
like a spiritual school that we're
collectively a part of and we need a
level up to the point where we can
unlock more of the
the next level that that is even cooler
powers even etc whereas right now it's
the fear and weaponry and that type of
stuff winning is it's it's cancers to
our up leveling and we're not able to
unlock those new skills that are
actually really beautiful and divine
let's let's do um the abolition of
organised religions this is again
there's so many points of nuance here
that that I that I hope we can get to
just one of them here is that like
religion is there's useful lines of code
in religion and there's extremely stupid
lines of code archaic lines of code that
need to go topside they're toxic so
because they're fair base so it's like
it might may be them
yeah it's fear-based my little point of
contention would be a little asterisk
and it would just say abolition of bad
lines of code and religion and like and
like also the idea that like here's an
end of their interesting point I've been
talking a lot about pantheism and I
mentioned it to you on the show as well
yeah all this God period like all that
is is God and we're all part of that and
we ourselves are God it's all God okay
cool
but then Islam and Judaism both actually
talk about pantheism so and this is you
know from my friends that have studied
it I haven't actually gotten to around
to getting deeper in it myself and I was
like that's profound so that means that
as long as we have some sort of a
different ways of the mountain to sacred
divinity then
is it then that it's like polishing the
bad lines of code but keeping the good
lines of code in a religion how do you
feel about that I'll make this very
simple
God did not invent religion man did we
would have God invented but if God
created us and we created religion isn't
that the transitive property in geometry
no because we actually created a
distortion by a lack of our
understanding mmm Oh again again you
call it lines of proof bad lines of code
or whatever it's the same thing it's a
distortion yes it's a distortion so then
if we had a pure connection to God and
source we would have made a religion
most religions are we would say faith
based it's not based on knowing through
experience if one person has a really
spiritual experience that absolutely
precludes any need for religious order
and everybody is has a divine right to
connect or reconnect with the Creator at
any time yes it's in it's very simple
there's there's no political nonsense or
fear in that there's it's required you
know most of those the gods of religion
are war
Jehovah Yahweh or and even what is they
is long term for it um god I'm blanking
a lot yeah these are these are war gods
or are our perception like you said it
like a shared hallucination our
misperception or distortion of what we
think God is it's not God to create a
religion God doesn't create weapons we
do that and we use that to them
wait wait wait wait so God there's
there's both you know that all this one
with mode ISM but there's also dualism
which is part of all that is God or
creation and that dualism is both good
and evil and as we talked about the very
beginning evil is there with the purpose
yeah and so evil is there with these
weapons evil is there with the fear and
that's there with the purpose and so
then it's a source that created it it
not humans or is a human's perception of
the source that's created fear yes and
we have a lot of help in that regard
like I said the program running in the
background we'll call it that's a little
tough distinction let's stay with that
for a moment so that we can at least so
at least if I can learn it maybe other
people can also understand I'm just
starting to understand it myself so so
then so then so we typically what I
think the string of thinking is normally
is that we have creation which created
good and evil and that we are baked into
that but really creation created create
created at the creative of this
experiment and then humans
misinterpretation of creation and
disconnection from source is what
created evil and fear no the fear and
evil was part of the code that was
written in there as I said the yes okay
so when we embrace amplifying it yes
okay so it was in the code but it could
be like dormant code look it's really
very simple when when I embrace love
there's no room for hatred or fear in my
heart that's right and when I'm
interesting when I did that I had such a
such a hard juxtaposition interesting
between evil the day that I shipped that
I saved that boy's life was bleeding to
death and I felt you and I saw the
parasites in the room
when I went up out to the mountain and I
started to resonate from my heart one
thing love-love-love it connected me
with the light it connected me with the
Father see in that see that was an
experience that was my and it took me a
long time to interpret it in a way that
I can articulate with people saying that
you know that I'm crazy but the bottom
line is is everybody has the divine
birthright to reconnect because it's
were all part of this family
and the distortion comes in when we
embrace fear and negativity and that so
it's an interpretation religion is an
interpretation of what the Creator is
okay so when we feel cuz this is an
experience that I know many people have
deep experience or wisdom yes sure it's
the idea of literally being unbounded
love and just being tied into source on
a divine god-like basis and just being
there and just being [ __ ] in love
with that then you're saying when you're
in that state there's no room for fear
right and that's beautifully said
because then then now we're saying all
the way back to source which is that if
we were all vibrating on that wavelength
of love peace prosperity there'd be no
room for fear and and there's no need
for dormant and then endures and there's
no room furniture okay not organized
religion like that everybody I talk did
they say I'm spiritual and not religious
yeah because religion is political it's
the politics of spirituality that we
don't really need that it's sort of like
the economic system it's based on fear
and lack there is no lack of anything
the creation is all about abundance
creativity connecting you know
connecting that was the other thing that
was shown to me when I was up in the
mountains
and now the was that they were all
connected to a walk through a web of
light science calls it a entanglement
yes but I saw it I've seen it I've
actually seen some graphics of it it's
it's it's very rudimentary because when
I saw it it was totally holographic and
I realized I was part of that web of
life one light yes yes and it's not just
light its information its emotions it's
everything it's everything yeah it's
like so how can we sit here and say on
polar I'm homeless
I'm sick I'm wood well hold on you're a
child of God you're in creation you're
not just sitting on a planet in a room
you're surrounded by a massive creation
by this intelligent that's creator that
loves you it's like hello are you paying
attention
no you're distracted by the fear you
know whatever it is whatever it is and
that you know like I said this is not to
judge anybody okay because I've been I
struggle with this my whole life I'm 59
I don't mind telling people I'm you know
I've been around
Robert looks hella good by the way I met
this was our first time meeting in
person and I was likes but I just know
the point is I'm not I know okay I look
young but I've actually been around I've
been to 59 countries in 59 years so far
so I've seen some of the world yeah and
that doesn't mean that I know anything
more than anybody but I've made an
effort to try and figure things out and
I've had a lot of help along the way you
know why because I asked I asked it's
okay to ask that's not a religious thing
by the way to ask for help you need his
religious ask from your parents can you
help me out no no and so but I was
surprised let me tell you when I would I
wasn't just sitting on that mountain
night going help I somehow intuitively
knew that what what I experienced that
day that boy with the with the boy and
his grandparents where he was bleeding
to death that that felt evil so what
does the opposite of that it was
frightening it really was frightening
okay and so I somehow I intuitively knew
that the opposite that would be love and
and so you could say it was accidental
or whatever believe me it wasn't a
logical thing I don't think love is all
about logic that's what I say
think less field you oh yeah we think so
much we kind of cut off this area you
know and actually you know hard math
Institute I think you were talking yeah
yeah they've actually mapped it this is
the biggest energy of field here but we
can increase it or decrease it only we
can do only we can do that for ourselves
yeah okay yeah you could say somebody
could be where you could be what he
targeted individual now directed energy
weapon system come on I know that stuff
is real but you don't have to
participate it I don't I know it's real
I know people try to screw with me a lot
because they don't like me talking about
these matters you know to being so
transparent or you know truthful but
it's my god-given right to to
communicate all right and I'm and I'm
doing more from my heart yet now can
tell when someone is speaking from their
heart versus their brain
you can tell it's hard for me it's hard
for me too it's it's a very beautiful
process of learning it's like going
through process of slowing down and
opening your heart and peeling unbound
love for the divinity into you and for
all the people that are watching about
it every Mart is reunify your self to
really connect doesn't matter whether it
is a glass of water or a beautiful bowl
of candy or there's lights out here or
butterflies I don't care that if you let
yourself connect to it on a heart level
yes you start to see the beauty and
everything and everyone it's funny
because in the contrasting perspective
of that is something like there's not
enough time the economy is roaring right
now we need to capitalize on the amount
of profits that we could make yeah if
you're sorry for people that go down
that path because ultimately they're
just screwing themselves yeah they're
gonna hurt some other people but
actually again
this is part of the circuit breaker the
negative people are attracted to each
other to do the negative deeds and it's
like an app here's the thing it's like
snow building up to a point where
there's just an avalanche you know
that's I know that's not the best
analogy to get or to well it's okay I
like these analogies so yeah breakers
avalanches garbage you know they used to
call those parables parables okay we're
getting somewhere we're getting us
really are figuring it out and it's not
complicated but it is difficult it is
difficult when you've been not
complicated but division yeah yeah yeah
because it's a soft work it's a lot self
because the longer you you've been
addicted to negativity yeah right the
more difficult it is to embrace the love
quotient and start letting that work on
you because it's it's through you I mean
it-it's like yeah through yeah through
you because see this is the thing that
it's the old code well I'm like is
enormous your computer can do a lot but
when you plug it into the internet now
it's got its got parallel processing
from millions of
okay the same is true for our soul we
connected the web of light to you
there's all kinds of stuff you cannot
download whatever yeah that's a great
way to put it yeah it's kind of like
when you get connected to the web of
light that you get to actually tune into
new channels that previously you may
have only been living life on channel 3
but now you learned that there's [ __ ]
channel 4 through 6 thousand yep and
there's also not only those channels but
then you also get to experience divine
beings and understanding what right air
channels are and like what their how
many channels bathe surf there okay so
alright that's again that's it you're
right but that's an intellectual way of
putting it yeah what about the love
potion if you you want want to increase
your love potion okay fine
love somebody else stir you got to love
yourself first but then what do you
start to do like here's that I was blown
away by I was wondering why was i wine I
ended up saving three people's lives in
such a short time when I was young
because it's usually that doesn't happen
to people right and I thought that was
really strange what's the purpose of it
until I read this children's book that
was an opportunity that was a gift to me
yeah
and I thought back and I'm like well I
mean it's you don't even use a reflexive
thing for me anyway I wasn't thinking
going well I'm more I'm earning good
karma Lursa no it wasn't like that it's
like holy crap somebody's gonna die you
know I don't know them I just want to
hell because because I have empathy i
still i'm intact i started whatever you
want to call it but I was reading this
children's book they said you know what
if you saw someone drowning
would you pray to God there you save
them or you gonna save them and it's
like and if you did wouldn't that be a
not only for that person but for you
that you did actually you were there to
do to do to do work of God
yeah you know to help the rest of your
fellow your family member
see that's the thing you know I said I
used to think like everybody else
because I was raised that way oh well
you're not part of my family you know
you're not part of my religion you're
not part of my country but the movement
started traveling around yeah I'm
meeting all kinds of people from around
the world I realize we're all in this
together people from around the world
really behave like if this ain't your
brother or they'll say sister well
auntie or uncle
they don't just call you like by your
name if you're a friend if you're friend
they call you that that they refer to
you as family yes yes I know this
doesn't say Wow okay so they haven't
lost that connection like stage stayed
over at our home TV with us yeah oh
there's that too yeah much greater
hospitality let's let's talk about
universal health care okay so what is
the deal with us not having I'm not
having like an adequate way for us to
take optimal care of our bodies and for
us to get rid of the amount of self
dealing that exists in the health care
system and replace that with inclusive
state holding with each other's health
we're super far away from let food be
thy medicine
he's like first principle ways things
were so far away from that now it's like
now it's like we're relying on on on
suffocating institutions that need us
we're dealing were relying on
governments to ensure us we're relying
on them to provide services to us
it just feels as though everything's
upside-down and backwards it is it is
because in another part of its it
they're not dealing with the emotional
aspect they treat us like machines or I
should say we permitted them to treat us
like we're just by all mechanisms that
they can slice and dice and medicate and
it does very little to deal with the
actual energy of who we are you know and
in that regard we're all held I think I
think we're all suffering we all need to
heal yes and again a big part of that is
forgiveness and you ever hear that well
I can get to any clinic no you need to
forgive yourself and let me tell you
something I'm like why I shouldn't say
this but my life is very very sad she's
the press I said well have you forgiven
yourself so for what I said look
just start start with one thing once
they see what happens what's three pages
later he's waiting you know she's like
oh my god I'm feeling so much better
yeah oh my god welcome to breathing then
welcome to writing down how we feel it
is our [ __ ] honor
yeah we're not into most of us are not
intestines are bushes so okay you want
to have universal health care first you
got to reform the health care system so
that it's really working for everybody
okay
it isn't I know it's all about profit
right now that's a big party but it's
not even functional it doesn't do the
job right and now that I feel is the
really big problem that nobody wants to
address yet some people little people
but I'm talking about in the medical
profession if you go in for a broken leg
you'll get your leg fixed
you'll get this [ __ ] big bill you
know if you especially going to
insurance but at least it works you do
get your legs fix right
but then there's okay there's - then
there's a bigger question why was your
leg broken
what lesson was to be learned I tell you
I don't have broken lot of balls at the
lesson I did I was on the tennis court I
fell backwards and I and I broke my
wrist I healed it up in about six weeks
and I avoided surgery that's crazy yeah
that's what the doctor said he said I
didn't want to tell you this but you
were so close to having surgery with
penance and more screws and I'm like
really because yeah I guess I'm amazed
at what you did well I said I hate how
you know but I do supplement tonight and
other sound therapy and also when they
saw somebody I needed to I talked to
this really great actor country sees us
we'll live you an even more than just
needles because I know how to do the
electricity I can put a leg
I can literally put electricity on both
sizes and we'll jump the gap okay I
don't I don't want to no no I said it no
more surgery I don't mind the cast I
just don't want to cut surgery on top of
this I said oh I know how I did this I
know what was wrong what I was thinking
I was really angry at least the inner
demons and I and I was cursing them
calling them ankle-biters stove you know
what I turned over my that see if you do
a good job at literally immediately
cease the lesson and that's big because
then you can have process other
questions and then growth from that I'm
just saying is it for all of us though
it's our an opportunity to heal on
multiple levels you know and ultimately
I realized I learned something very
valuable is it cursing the inner demon
is actually playing into the
correct you know it's a little too back
evil where I shine light it be pure
you rise above it with love and
compassion and good deeds in this life
just being pissed at them you know or
threatening them whatever but not only
that it actually is easy
it gives them license to them and
further attack us
let's try and do this from a redesigned
reset perspective them again so
healthcare yeah okay what would it look
like if we were to reset or reduce I'm
sorry thinking like you know the child
warns the world leading mediately the
first thing that the child is getting is
that local professionals parents
included water it's desert like it's
based on my family community and all
these other inclusive stakeholders that
care about the child's well-being okay
if the child gets sick then now the
question is or the adult gets said no is
it dulls ladies broken or sick what
whatever the deal is what happens at
that point how do we help people do
better
exist would like more focused on is
preventive medicine you're okay in a
holistic fashion and it levels that I
don't think are being even considered
right now we should be healthy we
a lot longer clean water food sleep
exercise the basics and there's other
like royal right we know we can be
brought instead of cell towers
broadcasting frequencies that disrupt
ourselves we could be broadcasting
frequencies that actually energize and
rejuvenate hours do you know what
frequency oh yeah sure it's very simple
it's and we already know what
frequencies healthy cells vibrate then
you have the code they know so we need
to pulse out a frequency better me so
like yeah I mean and that's part of
health care by the way okay that
shouldn't be part of health care and
this is holistic it's not just something
you do it after you've hurt yourself
it's it's it's preventative interesting
so good of the massive towers be pulsing
out those same frequency that healthy so
I'll tell you what I tell you to cover
certain if certain entities already know
how to do this it's called The Tree of
Life it's not a tree it's a cell tower
it's ancient technology
lanten's have that they've misused it
and ultimately cook their all
civilization collapse but the tree of
life and the tree of good and evil is
itself our technology that's what we
call it now all right so I'm going to
walk you through this I think I talked
about this before all the graphics I can
prove what I'm saying to you the Tree of
Life is a what we now call a cell tower
because it was broadcasting frequencies
that literally went into ourselves and
we do talk to the gods the so-called
gods of Atlantis they're not from other
planets they're from this one and they
went into the dark they went to the dark
side but anyway
the tree of knowledge of good and evil
it's the same thing it's it's what we
call cell towers it's this wireless
network technology and it is both we use
it for good other people use it for evil
you see that every day
the guy so people are just put in like
you know beautiful puppy love out there
no people early it's so toxic you don't
even want to talk to you know you know
just like Jenny's please right so that's
that those two trees not do us a robert
nuts that cell towers to are not trees
well guess guess what look around you
have you seen the cell tower disguise
that tree s trees it's the same thing
it's been here for thousands of years
it's just it was off-limits to us when
it was given to the modern version of
the workers the genetically modified
workers they're not from the gods are
not from anywhere other than this world
right they have to use the technology
because they the lack the spirituality
their science went up to here their
spirituality was down here they abused
the genetics they abuse the energies and
they literally collapse on itself but
then when they reconstituted it they
want to have this certain class so so
there's various levels of manipulation
or abuse I would say of the creation and
we didn't invent this stuff yesterday
technology like this has been around
forever and always will be it just it's
inherited
and what we are it's the abuse of the
dogs that is the problem so when they
talk about health care the universal
health care it is something that they
said before part of the thing is they're
not just making us sick they're making
us crazy with these cell towers that's
been proven it's it makes people or
literally violent you know and and it's
not a conspiracy theory that's just a
condition that we're suffering from so
as I said before we're all suffering
we're all on some level because of this
so that doesn't stop that has to stop
otherwise we're never going to be young
well we can't really heal when that kind
of violation is going on that distortion
is really cutting us off from the rest
of creation yes and it's you know again
it's a challenge it's done by design by
the dark side because he wants to
perpetuate itself this is really
interesting about code what they call
artificial life the first one the first
written was called sugar escape and it
was red and black digital hands fighting
over a disco hot with sugar and each
time the slightly different it was the
same thing there's very few rules in the
cupboard but they were fighting they
were completely to say they're competing
so this is another problem is the level
of competition that we accept in not
just healthcare but everything else but
especially since we're apartment
healthcare there she if there was a
level of cooperation in health real
health care across the planet a shared
benefit system whatever that may look
like I don't know but it has to be
global it shouldn't be as regional it
has to be global because we're all part
of the same never we're all part of the
same family here's the thing what we're
talking about it's not it doesn't take a
lot of money to do these things to
broadcast these frequencies it's mean
there's more profit in keeping people
sick and stupid and that's why they
perpetuate it okay so so the thing is
people need to do it so we're sitting
before about laying down the weapons the
only reason that this persists is
because because of the paranoia yeah so
then because there's more money to do
people but that's but that's a very
limited well that's that's profit wait
got it propaganda that's not that's not
peace and prosperity for everybody that
is allegedly profit for salsa at the
expense of
the way the many versions which is a
solution towards peace and prosperity
would be to do things like to take the
vibrational frequency of problem yeah
what you get is to assure hey it doesn't
take up for that and just to see if it
works I'm sure it will
and I'm sure there will be resistance to
it you watch got fast but what time
that's the tower of life retrieved a new
tree of life that's awful and that's why
it's not limits to us the guts forbidden
and who are the gods they're not from
some other world
they're here they've got the money
they've got the technology pause - now
let's resume at black and red ants
fighting for sugar just like there's a
big game of Monopoly that's being played
on planet Earth
yeah the whole level of competition is
artificial because again there's no
black there's nothing but abundance
everything is available to us the old
saying is God provided and man divided
it's again it's based on fear there was
something that they brought that keeps
popping into my head though about
healing you know some people have the
gift of healing and where is it coming
from this is not an endorsement for
religion by the way ok I just wanted I
wanted to I wanted to demonstrate
something to people here let's see if I
can get this on camera maybe you could
put that over the camera ok and then you
tell us about what we're what we're
seeing here yeah maybe just does bring a
little closer
yeah okay that's called the
Transfiguration of Christ that was some
time before he was crucified upon a
mountain that we still don't know where
it is but that's him under at night
basically glowing like a light bulb so
and now most people would recognize that
he is one of the greatest healers
allegedly then that we've ever known how
in the world did he do it he wasn't a
doctor it's because he he was radiating
that love that you see right there and
so there's it doesn't have to be
technology and really doesn't you know
it's again it has to it starts on a
holistic level at in the soul and heart
and most people don't even know that
this event even happened because
religions don't want to talk about it
because they don't understand it but
it's it's real what he was doing there
was healing the planet he was radiating
love to the entire planet even though he
knew he was physically going to be
crucified because of the fear that
people I mean that's the only reason he
showed up was to help us heal our hearts
so it took me forever to figure out what
was going on there because that made
zero sense to me why huh how does
somebody glow and all you know well but
I experienced that too not me personally
but I when I met September 22nd 1985
when I was on the mountain and I was
meditating or whatever and I went out of
my body and I met this guy said he was
my father he looked exactly like that he
didn't say I'm Jesus he just he was
radiating this light and I couldn't
figure it out because I had never even
seen that picture at the time I was only
you know I was a young man I didn't know
anything about Transfiguration of Christ
that only came later as I was trying to
understand the stuff and I do want to
put it in the context of healing because
when you are healthy you tend not to get
sick or fall down and hurt yourself
yeah or if you do you heal really fast
much faster
if you're pissed off and you're getting
all the pills it's somebody's stabbing
you and stitching you and whatever yeah
it'll work that's the really long way
around but it doesn't have to be like
that that's all I'm trying to say okay
Grady light and love and from your heart
from your heart and we will heal faster
have peace faster yeah yeah individually
and collectively I mean seriously
that's how he was doing those so-called
miracles you people didn't see the light
coming off of him but I'm guarantee it
was there I guarantee you was there yeah
that's a really important next step in
what some of our friends are doing with
their spirituality is they are figuring
out how to have a of a phosphorescent
rock that can sense prana and then the
more spiritually developed someone is
while they're looking at the rock the
more it the phosphorescence whoa yeah
yeah yeah so where there's a bunch of
interesting that would be like a love
meter to note it's about meter level
right - yes to understand the person
that's why I brought it up
hypothetically in a fictional sense that
exists in the books I was telling you
about that are on my website the Omni am
I the friend yeah so I figured somebody
would already has it and somebody else
here is going to come up with it
although do we really need to see that I
mean maybe I can see in people's eyes
but yeah then it's kind of like
something but that's the science
component - is potentially that you can
that could be interesting scene but if
you didn't listen here's the thing
you you either feel it or you don't it's
really impossible to fake when a person
is emitting radiating that love yeah or
not yeah I mean because like I said they
suck all these vampires you know the
dark side whatever psychopath they're
good at tricking people but only only
those who are still harboring a fear
that are looking for someone or
something else to save them rather than
doing the work and actually reconnecting
to the cosmos and then being in power
and healing themselves and then helping
others to do the same thing that's the
chain reaction that we're looking for
yeah that will solve all these problems
yeah
so one guy called in and said because I
was asking on the show if love is the
answer what is the question yeah he said
it doesn't matter what it is it's it
solves all the problems so just you know
that's kind of an idiotic question
well maybe the question is it's
irrelevant and maybe the question is
what is the meaning of life or love well
I think the meaning of life is to be in
love and so then that would be the
question potentially but yeah answer is
just love what about the world without
borders
whenever we have that initial overview
effect of seeing the planet without the
borders it was fascinating how more
spiritually awakened we became and right
and so we all want to live in this world
that are hard to know and feel is
possible yeah but right now there's this
like complexity of like okay I can't
just drop the border because then the
next day we will just have a bunch of
people show up in our country that's
happening anyway it's happening yeah
look even if you have the borders
there's people going to cross them
anyway the thing is it's artificial
mm-hmm just like time just like money
and to a large extent religion you know
that we've kind of touching on all this
this we're kind of going around the same
issue from different angles all right
I really think we're doing yeah just a
good thing if that's what holistic means
yeah you look at the whole thing from
every angle not just one or two angles
right yes so so borders is is a it's not
an illusion if you believe it that's
that's the shared hallucination you were
talking about before you have money time
and borders but truthfully borders only
exist because of a fear of so-called
other people anyway are other who are
others yeah no such thing no such thing
we're all part of the same family
yeah see and that's how you eliminate
borders that's how we will ultimately
eliminate border not just on this planet
but throughout all of creation we'll
start to like I said once we drop a lot
of this fear stuff enough of the fear
quotient is is goes down and we raise
our love potion
those other loving family members from
off our world are going to interact with
us and help us and show us a way to
become networked with all the other
civilized loving worlds yeah and there's
no borders between them it's not like
Star Wars or the federation you know and
they they're everybody's fighting with
everybody throughout the galaxy for
competing for something mm-hmm they're
they're cooperating and collaborating
they're compassionate they actually
enjoy sharing with each other like
family do family loves each other okay
and it makes it strong there's this an
old analogy about that one twig you've
been snapped to it's harder to read it's
almost impossible that's the strength of
the family yeah and that's the strength
of dropping all our borders too we're
under the illusion
that somehow we need them to be strong
to be a strong country no actually it
makes us weaker that perception is
cutting us off divide us up and
isolating us from each other yes in
propagating fear rather than I love you
yeah yeah I know I know it sounds like
I'm repeating myself no it's it's it's
actually you'd like you you just
described it we're looking at the
conversation of the path words peace and
prosperity from so many different angles
yeah that's why yeah yeah I really like
that it's a good it's just that it's not
a light switch like okay now vine like
the we we get that all the things that
we've been talking about have been we
want as part of our future
but we're purposely at this point
because we disconnected from source so
we had all these issues arise and now
it's not a light switch to turn off the
battle ins and to light switch up to
turn on the good ones it's just that
easy and so that way there's this like
titration process of how do we actually
transition to the world without words
how do we actually get universal here
how do we actually do global disarm than
receptacle command system abolish
organized religion like yeah okay let's
do cool governance and peace and
prosperity so let's wrap with these
thoughts okay no one else can represent
you not really not enough that's a
reality okay the whole concept of
advocating your personal responsibility
and saying you know my lawyer or my
politician or my priests or whatever my
doctor they're they're all need to
represent my best interests that is a
huge lie and it this none of this is
going to stop up as long as we keep
supporting that system individually see
this is this is a thing about personal
responsibility it's not just one thing
it's everything and that's where again
it's not really complicated it's just
hard it is hard to do this to start the
process and you have to be courageous I
think on some level not crazy but you
know why is courage
because this is a hoof positive here
it's an aspect of being in love with
yourself you have to say I can I can't
do these things I choose to do these
things and I know that I can't have help
I can ask for help if I'm if it's really
hard it's okay
doesn't mean you're asking somebody to
do it for you okay
but it's okay to ask them for some help
yeah and I told you it's happened to me
many times I wasn't even expecting to
help to come actually but I was
surprised when they came I was grateful
and it often came two times and in ways
that I wasn't expecting at all and it
literally took me sometimes decades to
understand how beautiful how profound
and and loving that help was or is you
know in my life and that's why I feel
obligated to share with other people I
don't always do the best job explaining
it because it's an embodied wisdom it's
an experience yeah but I try you know I
think it's important to tell the stories
which then give people more feeling
they're them put the feelers out to try
and also experience that themselves yeah
I share the stories around how people
feel it differently or you know
similarly yes as long as it's based in
love and positivity and just being
practical to them you know I don't think
anything we've talked about is I know it
may sound strange because some people
are hearing the story the first time
it's like whoa disarmament you know no
borders I mean what was this guy crazy
you know we can't live like that
well actually we can we just choose not
to the world our hearts all know as
possible and it's just that the
transition to get there isn't the light
switch which makes it harder and then
but the slow self work and the slow away
from fear towards love mentality across
the world we'll grassroots enable all of
the conversation well the time
unfortunately it's not like we have
forever I mean well we kind of do we
don't there's cycles that happen right
throughout the environment and we know
that nature and this world our solar
system which is actually called a
heliosphere it's not a flat thing like a
record it's a bubble of energy all right
coming out of the Sun and it is
transiting through creation we galaxies
whatever you want to call it but
essentially they called space weather
and we have entered our little bubble of
energy the solar system has moved into
this massive cloud of energy the NASA
for some reason calls the fluff other
people in the New Age call it the photon
zone or the photon band it's an age of
enlightenment literally we're in the
light we've moved into a much higher
energy region of of creation yes okay
and we're going to transit through it
for at least two three hundred years
according to NASA's you know estimations
or calculations and we have to get with
the program that's why the planet has
heated up actually all the planets
throughout the solar system have heated
up that's why you have more geological
earthquakes and volcanoes and weird
weather and just people basically if
they're negative that extra energy is
making them actually feel more it's
amping them up in a more you know that
negativity where's it gonna go you turn
it up if you're just seeing the freakin
metal music you turn up well you're
gonna get louder metal music it's not
gonna suddenly just shift just because
you crank up the amp so that's the
problem we're faced and that's why some
people are just losing it right now
because the the energy level is
increasing the amount of conscious
evolution happening around our planet so
rapidly through so many different
modalities the meditations the
psychedelics the neuro technologies the
connections to source across all these
different ways embodiments of indigenous
wisdom connections to nature I mean
they're just endless amount of ways and
that we literally feel it I mean this
program like a year and a half ago was
not as grounded in source it was not as
grounded in nature and the spiritual
wisdoms and so now all the sudden this
program becomes the more awaken
spiritually as well you know how as the
host that itself has as well yeah and so
it's just very interesting that I mean
even this show is an exact example of
what you were just describing and what
we were just talking about with this
overall consciousness evolution happen
around planet people are are really
wondering well where what is my way of
climbing up that mountain of conscious
evolution do I do this do I do that how
do I partake in the process and there's
so many different ways to pick from this
like Buffay ala carte of the process you
but like those long periods of focus of
climbing up the mountain and the sincere
self work towards love away from fear
will get us to the piece of property
yeah it's one step at a time like you
said you don't just flip the flip a
switch and end up you have to earn it
you have to work for it in order for it
to have value for you and individually
yes I should say but it's it's it's a
gift believe it or not this is a gift
and it's our divine birthright and if we
choose not to accept it that's
permissible unfortunately you can't
enforce enlightenment or love in
somebody's heart right they don't if the
person if soul doesn't not want to have
that connectivity doesn't want to have
that level of creativity peace and
prosperity
family that's their choice that is
designed into it as well freewill is
part of the process I'm only mentioning
it because I was shown that this is even
though there's a lot of us are gonna
choose this path back into the light to
connect with the
of light and all the creativity and the
prosperity and the peace and love and
happiness that comes with it so some of
us are too are going to remain in fear
some of us here will and yeah there's a
split I wasn't sure how that they were
going we're gonna coexist actually I
felt we couldn't coexist but they can
coexist it's just that one will be a
higher level of conscious evolution the
other will be fear-based
once we if we as you see if and when we
crossed a certain threshold a level with
the tipping point of love quotient here
yeah and the and the rest of our family
starts to come in and give us assistance
part of the assistance is that they will
remove certain individuals that are
danger to themselves and others yeah
they're not going to punish them they're
just gonna put them someplace safe
because the it's like I said about weeds
in the garden you know you can't have
this lush beautiful garden and permit
the weeds to keep growing in there it
inhibits the process yeah alright and
and so you know under the penal system
that we currently have just just
crushing them punishing them a cork
ihling people that you know you have
fear it doesn't go away that was the
really weird part it's like you keep it
it's still persist in the background
it's the subprogram running in the
background so we have to collectively
raise above it you know not to don't
just punish individuals that are
embodying yet we have to literally we
have to embody more of the love than
they embodied the fear the hatred in
order to really get the whole thing over
and then they just kind of fade out yeah
you know or like I said we get help we
don't help dealing with it in a very
benign peaceful and
the love quotient tipping point okay I
like that yeah good
that's our that's our next episode title
slash album cover slide film score love
quotient tipping well the thing is it's
a it's a paint attainable this is not
unrealistic what we're talking about I
know it sounds weird some people
nothing's impossible especially not
maximizing prosperities you wanna know
something my wife did it ad campaign
this is so cool let me just see this
you're gonna love this okay yeah that
way yeah yeah see actually she's like
the Scientology years ago it's really
obvious I don't let me come in backwards
on you or does this looks bad
it's um yeah those for those that are
just listening to you know Robert just
wrote impossible and then crossed off it
I am so there's just as possible now
yeah it's hey it's a great campaign to
be of the other one that I'm that I'm
familiar with this when it's a there's
like a guy that's kicking that I am off
of impossible and sure just as possible
yeah yeah it's all a matter of
perception it is a matter of perception
especially this one is the most
important is that we do ourself work
that we
develop peace and love and prosperity
and take the weeds of fear and so we can
continue cultivating the garden yes yeah
there's a component there a
consciousness is a huge part of it but
the creativity the level of creativity
that we can attain we've only just
touched the liquid we have different tip
of it yeah that's the big one is that if
you really want to see creativity
flourish then do this because then
you'll see the real creativity right now
it's just like a little tiny I know this
sounds a little bit certain like
circular logic but we were created by a
creator to be creative that's good I
like that
well yes it's true yeah okay but most of
us has a lost sight of it because we're
the fear creeps in and it overshadows
yeah creativity
okay we use our creative ability to to
manifest things that support the fear
instead of support the love and right
yeah created by the creator to be
creative I love it it's true it's just
it's it just doesn't get any more true
than that yeah I mean it's it's like a
thing most true if somebody can refute
that please I'd love to hear it I'd love
to hear
do that just kidding just well I would
be open please leave your thoughts in
the comments below about how to refute
that yeah I'd love to
we'd love to hear from you I know we
were born to be bad and killed people
created by greater to be creative I
guess the only refuting point that I
think some like science may argue would
be something like there was no point in
the creation and we are just here I've
heard done yeah
that's a very sad okay no I mean it
really is a very sad perspective it
means that that individual has lost
sight of creation altogether and more
importantly because they they cut
themselves off anybody can know this
stuff Alan it's not a secret
yeah it's not a secret it's absolutely
it's available to everybody all the time
yeah every breath of air is that right
there yeah yes in a - look in a person's
eye every drink of water every creative
expression well it's a little more
actually totally overwhelming when you
do plug into the web of life it's some
people they say when they have the
Kundalini awakened oh it isn't about
just the energy here it's what's coming
through through is overwhelming yeah
because that your consciousness is
basically overloaded and also like the
urges you it is but it's being really
high without any drugs it's amazing well
it's also if you I like you said if you
flip the switch you can blow the ball
that's a good point
you know because that kind of wattage so
you work your way up to be able to
handle all right all right right right
yeah titration of enlightenment yeah
the slower-paced
love group trajectory towards love peace
and prosperity yeah Robert this has been
another amazing conversation super
wide-ranging I've loved it so much you
know what a great topic the math of
peace and prosperity is so critical its
mission critical the most
mission-critical thing I mean yeah in
that big synthesis that needs to be more
prominent for what we're writing about
right now because if the first point is
that first principles that we all come
from source the second principle is you
gotta know thyself and know your North
Star maybe even the second principle is
peace and prosperity or maybe it's the
third principle peace and prosperity
right now we're also playing around with
you know create more value than you
capture but yeah peace and prosperity is
up there it's it's like literally the
point of the creation that was made by
the Creator is for us to figure out how
to be peaceful and prosperous and that's
like the ultimate test yeah but like I
said it's not complicated we make it
complicated that's where the difficulty
comes in is is literally facing our
inner fears pulling those weeds from our
heart now nobody else can do that we
have to do that for ourselves no drug
does that by the way no drug that I'm
aware oh who can do that for you yeah
that's the key is that the sincere self
work has to come ourselves but it's okay
to ask for help or help yeah yeah but
ultimately you have to make you have to
individually make the choice if we make
good choices based on you know good
information like this then we can move
forward collectively okay because it
actually does get easier the whole once
you're past the hard part right and you
start networking with other people that
have done the work well and you work
together well then actually you're
sharing the load and things actually
start to happen much easier much faster
and it much bigger way yeah it's not
like you're all alone carrying up a hill
by yourself yes yeah the the further
conscious evolution of more and more
people makes it easier and easier to be
a conscious being right now it's like
trying to be a tuning fork in the matrix
and so yeah yeah but more and more
people are waking up so this is like I
said the time is really important I
think if we don't get this done now we
may collapse yeah it could collapse it
so what it'll it'll recently set
anywhere but this is uh we would like to
see if we can break yeah let's see if we
can break through you know yeah that's
why I said it's a gift this particular
time and this particular information is
is if not for me or you put from Joe of
course you know told we're not just the
Creator but all of our extended family
throughout creation exactly the hundred
billion of us that came yeah and by the
way I finally solved the riddle which
came first the chicken or the egg
somebody has me the answer is
the Creator came before the creation
it's it's an old joke from the bird
tribe but anyways it's not it's not
meant to be funny the answer is actually
very profound it's it's an insight
basically here's another question that
would be I do think that that would lead
to pan in theism which then means that
the the the omniscient and omnipotent
deity or creator is that separate from
creation itself not necessarily not
necessarily you're right those two
things could Commission itself and so
you could I think that it could they
have happened at the same time that's
the question it could but I mean the so
then it didn't come before they came at
the same time which came first the
chicken or the egg a little bit of this
writer came before the creation what if
the creator just made the creation or
they were made at the same time I don't
think it was just one thing like he just
did I think therefore I am okay it's
like it was in the beginning allegedly
was this word whatever the word was this
vibration that we call creation could
have been love with probably but I mean
it was based on that so so all of the
various individual aspects that are
manifesting do take time I don't think
it all happened at one shot because it's
so complex it is extremely calm and it's
also organic the way we understand
organic it's very rare all right
it has an intelligence and it is
evolving so it took a long time to get
here but that that's all relative it the
thing is it well you know my music or
any form of creativity it's like oh I
did a song so now I'm done
no you said some point you're gonna find
in another song and another song right
are you gonna paint another picture
whatever because that's how creativity
is at each song and each painting is
slightly different and it's beautiful
they're all beautiful right so I did
anyway I'm sorry I kind of feel like I'm
running around in circles again but it's
beautiful
I don't know how why I was seeing
chicken and egg oh it's because some
people still struggle they they ignored
it like it's nothing it's actually very
it's a key it's supposed to trigger an
insight because it's a very relatable
one the chicken and the egg and which
one came first
it is the creator made the creation yeah
creator created sensation yeah lots to
be creative here's the thing here I
guess what I was trying to say is the
Creator it is self generated its self
generous yeah it didn't come from
nothing obviously it's always been
something or it couldn't be something
now it's always been something yeah but
it it did that that's what creativity is
it's right at the Creator come from it's
always just always been it's blank all
right but it's like it has all the
potential right here let's do what
creativity because what i'ma create or
yeah all right so fine that's me that's
my stats it's all self generated and
again this is why it's important to take
responsibility for ourselves for our
level of unity that yes yes okay instead
of just putting it out there and saying
I need to be staged okay I'll fix me
someone to manage yeah yeah because they
need to be governed I need to have a
politician yeah that's an ego yeah
versus versus literally feeling the
divine power within you being born by
creation for you to be creative and
fully owning your [ __ ] yeah well the big
part of is reconnecting with that if
force the force they say that's the
first principle is reconnecting with
source that
the first principle well the source it's
the force that the West a light source
yeah it's the web of light is the force
when you when we connect to that it
gives us all the energy information
creativity that we could ever possibly
need or want yes all right yes because
individually we're very relatively weak
like you know your computers is pretty
powerful but no no no when you put token
in the internet yeah it's the same for
us before eyes souls when we connect to
the web of light the force is with us I
like that one we're stronger like when
we plug the CPU into Internet well yeah
if you want to be stronger smarter
healthier and happier increase your love
quotient correct to the force or the
source or whatever you want to call it
the web of light yeah we would love to
hear the thoughts in the comments below
on that but so they'd love to hear from
you definitely let us know what you're
thinking about this path to peace and
prosperity about the different topics we
talked about global disarmament
resetting the global financial system
abolition of organized religion
universal healthcare the world without
borders ethical governance all these
have saying is the love quotient let us
know what you're thinking about all of
these things really do let us know and
how let's have a conversation about how
to best get there talk more to your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about how to best
get there and had just have more of
these conversations around us from
moving forward
practice that since your self work make
that a more common practice towards love
away from it fear and also check out the
links in the bio to unique is magazine
in the rest of Roberts work and also
check out the links to simulation as
well below support the artists
entrepreneurs to organizations the
spiritual leaders around the world do
you believe and support the Marlene
below to our PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency leasing and design cool
merch and get paid all that stuff's in
the bio and also do build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
it's a wrap that was a good one that
that was really good that is what the
best interview is that you told me this
is gonna rock yeah in her sand rocks
pronounced right I wasn't expecting to
go this well honestly I do know I mean
some kind of synergy collaborative
whatever we just did that was freaking
amazing but that's what's up like so so
actually a massive part of what we do is
like the interlocutor so like if the
inner locutor is has a bright world view
diverse world view and is able to
emotionally engage with the person draw
out their wisdoms play good tennis back
and forth yeah that's why afterward
people say that to us is like good [ __ ]
that was profound
[Music]
you
[Music]